émilie nicolas michel david jonathan
trudeau bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir
vous avez moins de temps donc je vais je
vais poser des questions courtes j'ai
été plus longs avec madame brochu qui
disait qu'un gel des tarifs mais ça
tombe sur le terrain politique c'est ce
que propose madame anglade c'est la pire
idée ça marchera pas bon ça va susciter
aussi des réactions mais je reviens sur
pierre
sainton rené lévesque on voulait faire
la paix monsieur bouchard qui avait
brassé pas mal de souverainistes en
disant ce qu'il a dit sur le pq
reviendrons pas sur tout seulement on va
l'écouter qui dit je suis peut-être allé
un peu trop loin dans cette longue
entrevue qui nous a donné on écoute j'ai
pu récemment mais j'aurais
personnellement que les héritiers de
monsieur lévesque n'ont rien perdu de
leur capacité de réagir avec la
vigoureuse se prostitue depuis qu'il est
toujours caractérisée à vrai dire quoi
que prononcer sur le vif
quelques secondes à la fin d'une longue
entrevue mes commentaires
pour le moins intempestifs et que je
formulerai autrement aujourd'hui
ce sont manifestement est justement
mériter une telle réaction
mea culpa le monsieur bouchard émilie
nicolas tour de table est dessus
c'est sûr que la soirée dias comme
souris qui étaient en forme non
seulement là dessus à mea culpa mais
aussi on a fini par
la parole tous les gens n'est pas
politique je comprends la logique à la
bad qui a été invité le premier ministre
en tant que chef d'état à prendre la
parole puis si on a remis ça en question
avec la question bon bien sûr chef du
parti québécois c'est ouvrir la porte à
ce que tous les partis politiques à
éviter aussi que je pense qu'au final
c'était probablement la bonne chose à
faire salle envoyer le message que
finalement tous les québécois peu
importe l'option peu ils peuvent se
trouver
pour tous les québécois donc un sens que
je pense que c'était le bon message
envoyé depuis la réconciliation qui
s'est passé hier aussi elle était debout
en bon michel qu'en penses tu qu'en
pensez vous pour ce qui de monsieur
bouchard honnêtement
ça faisait une très bonne entrevue mais
c'était pas un ancien chef du pq de
donner le coup de pied de l'âne à son
ancien parti ça va déjà assez mal au pq
franchement monsieur bouchard il me
sembla aurait pu se garder une petite
gêne pour ce qui est de la soirée d'hier
bon ça se voulait rassembleur mais quand
on écoute quand même les discours il y
avait il y avait beaucoup de politiques
y avait beaucoup de flèches envoyé aux
uns et aux autres et je comprends et ça
ne me choque pas du tout monsieur
lévesque était porteur d'un projet qui
est encore l'objet de débats alors on
peut pas parler de monsieur lévesque
sans parler de ça et les gens qui sont
actuellement au coeur de ce débat là ne
peuvent pas non plus en faire
abstraction et je trouve que je
comprends d'ailleurs st pierre plamondon
qui voit que tous les chefs de partis
non souverainiste essai de de
s'approprier monsieur lévesque et lui on
l'avait même pas invitée ce qui fait de
ce qui était à mon sens une absurdité
mais mais qu'on fasse pas semblant que
j'en bouffe parler de monsieur lévesque
sans tomber dans le débat sur la
souveraineté ça me semble stoppée
jonathan
moi je trouve que c'est moche en rien à
leur prouver quel point les
lithographies mille et un politicien gg
impression j'ai envie de dire que les
plus grands ne sont pas sûrs qu'ils
prétendent ne jamais commettre d'erreurs
mais ceux qui sont capables de le
reconnaître de le faire avec classe avec
grâce avec dignité c'est exactement ce
qui lui ces mouchards fait jamais les
mots qu'il a employés il le fait avec
une touche d'humour je pense que c'était
bien senti non c'était pas nécessaire
qu'il un globe a été la semaine dernière
mais ici c'est amendé et tant mieux
maintenant moi je pense que ceux qui
étaient les plus perdant dans tout ça
c'était les gens de la fondation rené
lévesque qui voulait lancer l'année
l'évêque dans l'enthousiasmé finalement
eu tout ce brouhaha l' heureuse maillard
finalement l'harmonie était revenu mais
en même temps j'ai pas pu m'empêcher
trouvé qu'il y avait un fond de
pertinence à leurs envies de tenez
vraiment un élément qui soit non pas ça
parce qu'on le veuille vous réunissez
les chefs des différents partis
politiques est immanquablement il y aura
des petits excès de partisanerie rien
pour faire de grands drames de grands
scandales et je pense justement à port
st pierre plamondon à gabriel
nadeau-dubois les deux chefs les plus
jeunes qui ont été de petits
sous-entendu à ses partisans pour pour
piquer un peu entre autres françois
legault je pas certain que ça avait sa
place mais bref heureusement nous avons
été là et ça c'est qu'on veut entendre
par st pierre plamondon justement un
court extrait d'hier soir
il parlait je le cite des effet
déprimant d'un régime usé désuet qui est
anormal dans lequel on se paralysent
mutuellement d'un bout à l'autre du pays
des mots d'une cruelle actualité
gageons que si rené lévesque tenait
encore la plume dans une chronique du
journal de montréal
il aurait employé exactement les mêmes
mots faux semblants hypocrisie pour
commenter l'actualité politique des
dernières semaines
alors oui si vous faisiez référence
jonathan je recommence avec vos tours de
table sur
il ya eu des points est assez directe à
cette actualité ce bouillonnement auquel
on assiste depuis plusieurs semaines
drainville saint-hilaire etc bouchard
etc
écoutez moi c'est pas un secret le je
suis je suis un fédéraliste je ne m'en
cache pas je travaille pour deux
gouvernements fédéralistes donc c'est
certain que ma perspective c'est devant
un chef de parti politique qui profitent
du centenaire de rené lévesque d'un
élément de commémoration qui en passant
souligne l'entièreté de la carrière de
rené lévesque évidemment on retient son
passage
marquant historique qui à la tête du
parti québécois mais il n'ya pas que son
ne pas on pense au journalisme ça va
être soumis par le gouvernement avec le
grand prix rené lévesque son passage
aussi au parti libéral du québec il est
un acteur incroyable de la révolution
tranquille donc il n'ya pas que ça mais
clairement pourquoi saint pierre de
l'amour dont il y avait une opportunité
de brandir si on veut l'un espèce de
drapeaux de dire écoutez on doit parler
de souveraineté c'était de bonne guerre
mais est ce que ça va changer quoi que
ce soit je suis pas certain ouais michel
emilie est rapidement michettes ouais
non je pense pas que ça va changer quoi
que ce soit à la trame si les trois
prochains mois mais je pense que
monsieur c'est un père blanc monde on
avait raison monsieur lévesque était
d'abord il n'ya jamais arrêté d'être
critique du régime fédéral
c'est pas parce que qui a pris le beau
risque qui pensait pas que la
souveraineté était la meilleure solution
et c'est vrai aussi que au cours des
dernières semaines qu'est ce que vous
voulez quand on a vu de rainville on a
vu caroline st-hilaire il ya personne
qui pense vraiment que ces gens là sont
devenus de tout d'un coup devenu des
amoureux du canada à loriol je comprends
l'amertume de monsieur st pierre
plamondon et je comprends qu'ils aient
profité de l'occasion pour commander
étalé ses états d'âme sur la place
publique ml
mais vraiment je pense que je le point
que jonathan kent façon le prix de
journalisme et le taux de mentions aussi
parce que ça suscite un malaise je pense
que j'ai plus à jean marais c'est
notamment à la fédération
professionnelle des journalistes du
québec parce que on a finalement premier
ministre qui décide d'octroyer la plus
grande ampleur à des journalistes en soi
quand le gouvernement décide qu est ce
qui est bon journal et sassou livre ça
soulève beaucoup de questions et donc je
pense qu'effectivement il ya eu une
tentative d'envoyer par par la bande un
peu des flèches partisans
du québec solidaire aussi mais en même
temps le saint françois legault aussi
comme premier ministre utilise étude
exhaustive qu'il a comme pouvoir comme
premier ministre pour faire des choses
qui sont certes raisonnée ram et en
partie aussi politique donc je pense que
finalement c'était
quand on est à trop
bon ça va se poursuivre je rappel il est
né le 24 ou 22 l'évêque donc il y aura
d'autres événements comme ça
martin ouellette qui quitte le parti
québécois on a un petit extrait où il
explique pourquoi on revient tout de
suite après
les raisons de mon départ sont
uniquement personnel
et bien honnêtement sans prétention avec
les commentaires reçus sur la qualité de
mon travail j'ai confiance que j'aurais
eu l'appui des citoyens pour poursuivre
mon rôle à l'assemblée nationale mais le
temps passé loin des miens a usé ma
motivation et les sacrifices
supplémentaires ont pesé dans la balance
la question c'est plus tellement qui
se représente pas mais qui se
représentent joël arsenault mégane perry
melançon et pascal bérubé je crois que
c'est les trois seuls sauf erreur michel
david je commence avec vous comment vous
lisez qu'est ce que vous lisez d'abord
lisez-vous quelque chose de ce départ où
c'est vraiment une question personnelle
bon on est obligé de prendre la parole
de monsieur ouellette s'est dit que pour
des raisons familiales il est épuisé
très bien mais ça change rien à la
situation c'est un autre affaire c'est
maintenant plus de la moitié du caucus
péquiste bon il n'était pas très gros
mais quand même qu'ils quittent et on
peut pas s'empêcher de regarder les
sondages puis les projections puis
monsieur monsieur ouellette a beau dire
qu'il aurait été réélu je pense que nos
offres je pense que monsieur mon mimi
montigny dis-je dans de rené lévesque
votre élu candidat de la cac et c'est
humain est là quand on s'en va vers une
défaite presque certaine disons que ça
nous aide à trouver d'autres bonnes
raisons pour pourra l'aider on relever
un nouveau défi alors oui j'accepte les
raisons de monsieur ouellette mais je le
constate que le pq dans un cul-de-sac et
que le genre pas vraiment google à
l'abattoir vous parlez de yves mon team
iwuy et des papiers comme beaucoup c'est
le maire de baie comeau
donc qui aurait de bonnes chances
candidats pour laquelle jonathan ce que
ces faits d'abord d'après vous ouais
vous savez déjà plusieurs semaines
comment parle il reste à confirmer le
tout avec avec françois legault et
éventuellement le vivier d'être réélu
pour un deuxième mandat ce qui ne trompe
pas la mairie de baie comeau a noté
qu'il a déjà été battu à l'investiture
du parti québécois contre ce même me
martin ouellette un autre qui
soudainement revu la lumière a vu la
lumière caquistes est forcé de marc t on
à l'être j'ai eu l'occasion de discuter
avec lui moi je remet pas du tout en
question ses motifs fo faut pas oublier
qu'elle est racontée qui est loin à baie
comeau de façon erronée casser le comté
de rené lévesque survient au lendemain
des lancements des cérémonies entourant
le centenaire de rené lévesque il a deux
jeunes enfants veut faire un retour dans
le privé espèce de rumeurs farfelues le
quai circulent aujourd'hui qu'ils
feraient une espèce de de changement si
on veut que lui se présenterait les
mérites des comores confirme qu'il n'en
est rien en même temps c'est vrai ce que
michel didon et enée changent leurs
études les choses walt ebell échanges
oublier ça c'est complètement farfelu ça
n'arrive pas mais on sait pas ce que ça
aurait donné avec les sondages peut-être
qu'il aurait vu les choses si rama mais
chose certaine du coup au niveau de la
perception c'est plus de 50% des députés
du parti québécois qui ne se représente
pas 4 sur 7 seriez pour aider à
l'ambiance aux perspectives en vue de ce
3 octobre prochain disons ouais c'est
aussi ça la réalité ml
c'est sûr que beaucoup de départs au
parti québécois mais je pense est
important de rappeler qu'un nouveau site
beaucoup eu au parti libéral à la caq
s'il ya des départs en masse mais aussi
beaucoup de départs donc je pense que
c'est sûr qu'un élément politique là où
il ya le plus de départs qu'on peut dire
c'est les gens intelligents qui en plus
dans son animation pas du tout qui vont
pas très bien mais je pense que ça
prendrait la peine de faire un post
mortem sur
comment est-ce que c'est passé la vie
politique lors d'une pandémie aucun
rêver lui lorsqu'il s'est présenté aux
élections qui avait comme ambition de
gérer le québec dans une crise
historique comme celle là donc il ya
beaucoup de départs pour des raisons
familiales parce que la politique est
éreintante donc moi je me pose la
question est ce que la politique a été
plus dure un temps que d'habitude là tu
qui sont pouvait faire des entrevues
sortait avec plusieurs personnes qui ont
quitté le fêter aussi les pouvoirs
extraordinaires qui ont été accaparées
par le gouvernement qui fait en sorte
qu'il était très difficile pour les
partis d'opposition ne soit pas rentable
c'est sûr aussi que fade et bottines
lorsqu'on est près de quatre heures
d'actualité de continuer si on en plus
on n'est pas sûr de gagner certainement
très incertain
la caq de rené lévesque dans la
circonscription était arrivé pas si loin
d'ailleurs la dernière fois pour ça
michelle vous dites ça a été dur on ne
sait on le saura jamais mais ça a été
dur ça a été très difficile a nettement
tout le monde fait arrive à peu près à
la même conclusion que pascal bérubé
risque d'être le seul à rester au pq
après après le 3 octobre alors monsieur
montigny bon on verra mais il ya toute
la cac derrière lui là je pense qu'elle
ya beaucoup de gens qui un peu comme au
moment où les gens en 93 encore
personnes connaissaient les candidoses
palikot monsieur montini lui est connu
mais les gens votaient lucien bouchard
et là il ya deux les gens vont voter
françois legault dans une large mesure
même s'ils connaissent pas le candidat
dans leur circonscription on va avoir
l'occasion d'en reparler merci beaucoup
g12 écourter un peu continue madame
brochu merci à la prochaine au revoir au
revoir
à voir pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et redit